un año después de que se convirtiera en
el epicentro de la crisis sanitaria en
europa italia superior el hito de más de
100 mil muertes por coronavirus esta
nación fue la primera en imponer un
cierre a nivel nacional en marzo del año
pasado cuando el hobbit 19 saturó
hospitales y morgues en su primer
discurso público desde que asumió el
cargo el primer ministro dijo que el
país enfrenta una nueva ola de casos my
habremos pensado nunca hubiéramos
pensado que un año después nos
encontraríamos ante una emergencia
similar la pandemia no ne áncora la
pandemia aún no ha sido vencida pero con
la aceleración del plan de vacunas
podemos ver una salida que no está muy
lejos la campaña de vacunación en italia
tuvo un inicio lento en parte a los
retrasos en las entregas de las
farmacéuticas el nuevo gobierno aumenta
cada vez más la presión sobre los
fabricantes para que cumplan sus
contratos también está dando prioridad a
las vacunas en los puntos críticos donde
hay brotes y está flexibilizando las
restricciones de edad para las vacunas
de astrazéneca para incluir a los
mayores de 65 años superando las dudas
de que el medicamento podría no ser
eficaz en ancianos
en francia las autoridades dijeron que
las personas que se contagiaron de kobe
19 entre 3 y 6 meses antes
recibirían una dosis única pero antes
que los espero que el estado y la región
puedan acelerar el proceso y que puedan
llegar a todos cuanto antes estemos
todos vacunados podremos volver a
nuestra vida normal varias regiones
también han hecho cierres locales ya que
la reproducción del virus aumentó
exponencialmente en las últimas siete
semanas